وقعت الخطوط الجويه البريطانيه وهيئه
الاذاعه البريطانيه بي بي سي وشركه بوتس
وقعت الاسنادان ضحيه قراصنه روس تطلق على
نفسها اسم كلا ونتج عن عمليه القرصنه سرقه
بيانات رسميه لاكثر من 100 الف موظف هذا
وطالب المقرصنون بفديه ماليه مقابل رد
البيانات قبل الرابع عشر من يونيو وفي حال
عدم دفع الفديه هدد القراصنه بنشر بيانات
الموظفين على الانترنت بما فيها طبعا
تفاصيل حساباتهم المصرفيه وهنا اكد المركز
الوطني للامن السيبراني بانه يعمل بدقه
لمعرفه ملابسات عمليات القرصنه وتاثيرها
على المملكه بشكل عام لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات